[Musique]
rien n'y fit
gaylard 4 m eur
je reviens au regard des liens donnant
une forte dans son poisson pour tout le
monde parce que si c'est compliqué tant
d'années que je ne veux pas rater ce
temps
si il a volé
doucement web à thiriez ou si on sera
regardé je ne ressors les bulletins à sa
descente quasi deux idées de génie
[Musique]
et non ils sont réels mais c'est
l'absolue s'étaient tous les segments
peu de magie dont j'écris fils comme
jamais
ce qu'a fait l'équipe c'est une première
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une bonne
ambiance les commanditaires ont été
hyper engager leur tour
si vous connaissez c'est l'essentiel
[Musique]